tonight we hear from a 92 year old woman
whose car wasn't stolen but burglarized
leaving her without a way to get around
madison kimbrough joins us live with her
story tonight
yeah we're here near monterra meadows
retirement facility and that's where the
theft occurred at this parking lot you
can see behind me it happened sometime
last night and for marion demario who
still drives her truck to get around the
sentimental value behind the car is why
she gets so emotional thinking about the
whole ordeal
and i've taken care of it just like a
baby
i mean
the maintenance is always done and they
go over it with a fine tooth comb if it
needs anything 92 year old marion
demario has lived in las vegas for over
60 years and tuesday morning she woke up
to this i came down to go to breakfast
and i thought gee do i have a flat tire
i want to look and that's what i found
was all of my wheels were gone on all
four
marion immediately contacted management
at the retirement facility she lives at
but due to the lack of security cameras
they didn't have any leads marion then
called the police to file a report and
while they took down her information
they never made it out to look at the
burglarized truck demario says this
truck is so much more than just a mode
of transportation as it was a gift given
to her almost 30 years ago from her late
husband marion's daughter says this all
could have been avoided if the
retirement living community of monterra
meadows had fixed their facility's gate
to my understanding it has been
not functioning for over a month
and this is something especially in this
community with all the seniors this
should have been repaired the day of
that it didn't work properly because
this makes them all so vulnerable it's
terrible because how are they going to
feel safe
demario's family has set up a gofundme
page to help with the cost of replacing
the missing wheels and tires if you
would like to help marion we have a link
to that gofundme page up attached to
this story on our website reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now